all right we back at it again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
i think you know i gotta reach over and
turn it off because as
as always i'm a one-man show i've gotten
some emails from people talking about
they wanna hey i'll be your assistant
i'll be your producer
and i actually am seriously looking into
that guys if you live in the la area
or actually you don't i guess you don't
even have to live in la area just
anybody that's interested in really
being an intern for riffing with griffin
to help me take this to the next level
artists musicians all the kind of people
that have been you know if you want to
send me art you want to work with me you
want to be like you know
do my thumbnails if you know musicians
you know you guys have been sending me
music this whole time i'm actually
working on a
mixtape for a war zone with a buddy of
mine alex acosta he's actually a great
musician
uh lyft god is his uh rap name you could
he you actually find him on uh
spotify he's you know so we actually
been collaborating
to make some songs to make like a funny
you know
call of duty warzone mixtape like all
based off war zone
so we got a couple of couple of tracks
in gear and my and matic productions who
have sent me many beats in the past he
sent me a couple of really dope beats so
you know look out for that kind of stuff
but anyways just to say like if you
if you're looking to help if you really
like the show and you go man if he just
did this
this show would really blow up or if you
think you could be that person
i'd be more than happy to like you know
take your emails and
we can discuss it what's up guys it's
eric griffin i want to talk to you about
helix sleep once more but i want to talk
about my helix sleep mattress
uh i finally got the mattress and i got
to tell you it's the best mattress i've
ever had
just the whole mattress process usually
you know you go to the store you got to
pick out a mattress and they got to come
to your house and
or you're deliver you're carrying it up
or you're helping them carry it up you
got to move things out of the way the
mattress is
knocking over lamps and you know it's
just a whole rigamarole this one
the mattress comes tight in a box
i don't even know how they do it i don't
know how they do it but that's what
happens
it's all tight and then you open it up
you put it out and then it just unfolds
then you have to let it sit till it like
you know gets to the shape that you want
it in
but it's great and it
they made it so easy it's so comfortable
it was made
exactly for me i mean this is the
important thing about healing sleep it's
one of the best
uh things about the whole process is
heavy sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress
for you right you hear what i'm saying
they match the mattress
for you i got the which one did i get
what's it called i got
the the uh i'm a side sleeper so i got
the helix sunset lux
it's got a soft feel um the side
pressure
and point relief you know that's their
whole thing so they really
customized the mattress to what you want
what's perfect for you
so i got to tell you guys i highly
recommend
helix sleep everybody's unique
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium firm
mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot or
you know what i mean and it even has
plus size mattress for you plus size
folks
so make sure you go to heated sleep i
took the quiz and like i said i got
the sunset model it's you know it's soft
it's perfect for me because i sleep on
my side so if you're looking for a
mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
it's matched to you and the mattress
comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to the mattress
store
again helix sleep i'm telling you right
now it's awesome
but don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one
best overall matches pick of 2020 by gq
and
wired magazine this is the important
part too guys
go to helixsleep.com griffin
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
other important things are they have a
10-year warranty
and you'll get to try it out for a
hundred nights
hear that you can sleep on the mattress
for a hundred nights risk-free
and they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but i'm telling you
right now
you're gonna love it all right helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pedals for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
griffin hear what i'm saying guys
slash helixsleep.com take it from me i'm
sleeping a lot better now
because of healing sleep helix sleep
y'all helix late get it let's get back
to the show um but you know welcome back
to riffing with griffin and again and
again like i stream daily on twitch on
my other channel eric griffin gaming
uh i put up the videos but i'm on twitch
daily at air griffin gaming so you guys
want to check that out make sure you do
another week here you know another week
down another another week going uh
you know the presidential election is
it's over now we're just waiting to see
what's gonna happen with these uh you
know what's
what is trump gonna do is he just gonna
be like all right you won man i'm gonna
move on with my life
personally i think he's going to be i
think he's going to be better for it
i think that all this hate and vitriol
that the people have for him
they're going to they might forget about
it some people think that they'll be
scarred forever from what they
perceived him to do or whatever i don't
know
but who knows what he's going to do
after this now he could just deal with
his businesses you know he could just
make his trump empire grow now he's got
like fans you know what i mean he's got
70 something million people who think
he's this [__]
so that can parlay into like you know
billions of dollars in business you know
he could start his own
network he can take on because he was
like apparently mad that fox news called
the election so now he might start his
own he could start his own news start
his own thing
i mean i think it's gonna be great for
his business career
i mean unfortunately if you know if
you're not a fan of his you know it's
like damn he's gonna capitalize on all
that he
did or didn't do you know i'm not trying
to talk politics anymore
but you know it's like we're not gonna
know we're i just think we're in flux
right now until
uh january 20th if there's going to be
an inauguration of biden and
um kamala harris you know who knows who
knows what's going to happen up to this
point i i don't know if they've actually
certified their election results i don't
know what's going on with these lawsuits
i don't know
i actually don't know anything that's
going on i think that what happened i
don't think anybody expected it to go
actually as smoothly as it did because i
know they were boarding up like
businesses and stuff because they
thought oh man if this person wins
these people are going to do this if the
other i just think that we're actually
better than we really thought we were
because it was so
i don't know why it happened the way it
happened you know it's like that night
we knew uh we already knew oh
we're going to have to keep counting it
was closer than we thought it was going
to be
for the electoral votes and it was like
we just then we just kind of like oh
let's see what
happens and then there was no big outcry
on either side
i think that's the democratic process in
motion and i thought it you know i
thought it worked well
you know i think it's working well now
we'll see if
january 20th biden is brought into
office and the whole thing works
smoothly you know regardless of
the guy i mean if trump's throwing a
temper tantrum
first of all i don't know why you're
shocked okay like if you're
a liberal and you've been talking [__]
about this guy for four years
why are you now oh my i can't believe
really [__] really really you can't
believe
he's acting the way you've been talking
about him for four years now
and now you want to be like outraged
still like shut up
like you people that are still outraged
shut up
like don't be shocked just be like well
you know here's another day with this
guy because at this point like you're
preaching to the choir all the time it's
like okay you don't like him yes he did
this and now yeah okay now oh look what
he's doing
don't you shocked by it it's like i'm so
sick of it you know
and so like and then like you know if
you're
shouldn't he be upset you know it's like
you're it's like
one of the most hardest stressful jobs
ever it's such a prestigious job
there's only been 46 other people in a
hundred years
and you lose your job you're not in you
not
you can't take a moment and be like damn
i mean i guess you know i guess if
you're supposed to be the president
you're supposed to carry yourself in a
certain way and that's probably what's
been wrong with the guy in the first
place but
anyways i got no problem with the dude
having a temper temperature
for a little bit you know because that's
who he is you know what i mean volatile
explosive guy he's on twitter i think
he's the first president to ever be on
twitter as much as he is i don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing but
what's it gonna be moving forward
um i don't know i mean twitter is it's
crazy
twitter instagram all these all these
kind of products like you know it
it's like being used by politicians like
that's the sign of the times like
how crazy is that i know i was on
fighter and a kid it was great to see
those guys again
um i always have a good time on that
show so make sure you check that episode
out
uh one of the things from there that i
thought was really funny was like
apparently the pope likes some big booty
picture
because the pope's now on instagram but
i mean i
you you just got it it's probably fake
it's probably easy to fake that just put
the guy's name right there but who knows
if that was real or not
but check that story out that just was
weird that's one of the things we talked
about on uh
on uh fighter and the kid so make sure
you check that out
so what's going on with me i i'm i'm
trying to move
you know i live in l.a i'm not moving
out of la i'm just trying to move um
i live in like a townhouse type place i
live in culver city
i'm not gonna give you my exact address
but anyways my
rachel hates it she she just hates my
place but i think that happens a lot
when you're in a relationship with
somebody and then they move in with you
they kind of feel like this ain't theirs
like this is like oh this is your place
so she just finds everything to hate
about
i hate the carpet i hate this or the
appliances the
the shower is too small and there's all
there's just always something so i just
i finally caved i was like fine let's
move
but because i've been living here so
long and it's rent control
you know i pay a good price in
comparison to
where it is now in the area so i started
to go look
and my goodness man have you all looked
at the rents in los angeles at some of
these places
i just don't know who enough who's
paying this
like who's paying the rent at some of
these places
like it don't make any sense to me man
it don't make any sense
so like right now if you want a good
two-bedroom
place now west side santa monica culver
city
mar vista bermuda del rey like all those
kind of places
you ain't getting nothing under 4 000.
let's just open with that right there so
it's going to be 4 000 a month
plus all right to find a place
that you uh you know to find a place
just two-bedroom place just a
two-bedroom place
now for me i got upstairs downstairs
two-bedroom
washer dryer in the unit you know i got
all the things you know i like the
spacing of it i i love my place right
but i was a bachelor guy for so long so
you know you don't even think about
the other things that when a woman comes
in your life the things that she
thinks are important you look at those
things and at first you're kind of like
what but then you start to go
oh yeah all right and then you you know
you you they they improve your life man
just a good partner
improves your life because they expand
your thoughts man
and so that's what she's doing for me
you know and it's just and i go okay now
i'm starting to look and i go yeah i
don't like this
you know what i mean i do want it's time
for a change you know it's just
i asked my building manager i was like
people stay here
average of two three years i've been
here way longer than that you know
that's why probably why they want me out
so they can like raise their rent but
anyways
regardless actually i think they wanted
me to stay because i've been paying rent
anyway so
i'm looking around man i saw okay so
there's this place
over there they built they're building
up the train station all right and so
they're building this like complex
that has like shops and stores and they
have this these apartments
these like luxury town home apartments
so i went and i looked
and i went to like the floor plans they
have like three bedroom floor plans they
have two bed you know
these suckers are like 9 000 a month
did you hear what i said 9
000 a month that's almost
120 000
a year 120 000
of you you stay here three years you
would have spent 360 000
that's a freaking down payment on a
million dollar home
you know i don't get it like i don't
get who the clientele is
nine thousand okay so there's some
apartments there's an apartment off
um la cienega near the beverly center
okay it's this they got a trader joe's
on the bottom floor
it's this like luxury apartment
penthouse
type just super like valet parking
you know doorman type of apartment
complex
and these suckers are like 20 000 a
month
plus okay that's where they're listed at
you know 13 15 000 up to 20 000 okay
that i almost understand because you
you're rich okay you're like
that's something like filthy rich and
your kid you you're sending your kid to
ucla and you haven't stayed there
because you're like a shake
from the middle east or something or you
know you're some company and you're
putting people up or i don't know it
just to me it's like i can almost
justify the super luxurious apartment
you know at a certain price you're
getting all these amenities
and it's the certain kind of people that
got so much money they don't even have
they they keep an apartment in la
and you know or it's like a basketball
player who's like trying out for the
clippers or something and they're
staying here for six months and they're
gonna get this apartment because they
want to live their life okay
i get those like super expensive but
when you get down to like
nine thousand even six thousand so six
seven eight nine thousand dollars a
month who's that
who are you who what are you doing
you want to talk about living beyond
your means like you have to be living
beyond your means to be to want that
kind of place
or like you think you're rich or you're
you're overspending i i just don't get
it i don't
get 9 000 a month apartment
what is that what what how much money
you got to make
a month it seems to me that if you got 9
000 a month money you ain't gonna live
where this apartment is
so i don't get the people that are are
that made this
i don't get their their mentality what
what why would somebody this
this with this kind of money want to
live on in this part of town
you know next to all this next to the
train
you know what i mean i just i don't get
it
i do not get it i hate it and then you
know of course everybody's always like
buy a house
you should buy a house and maybe there's
some financial experts that listen to my
podcast and you want to send me a
message about it but
i'm not big on that the money i've made
in the last 15 years from being on
numerous television shows and movies
i ain't a million i ain't a millionaire
i'm not a rich dude but i got my money
in the bank and this
and i i'm invested i'm in the stock
market i got financial advisors i got
my account was up 20 last year so i'm
fine with where i'm at in terms of that
you know i could have bought a house
before but like why
like why people always say like buy a
house
have property okay let's let's even just
say you bought a house at 500 000
okay and then 10 years later your house
is now worth 900 000.
okay you sell it you go oh look at this
profit i made
but where are you going to live now so
if you sell it are you going to buy a
new house
because if you buy a new house you
actually didn't make any profit because
you got to put
all that money into the new house the
only time
the only time to me and i could be wrong
but the only time to me
that you making a profit is if you
bought a house let's say you buy a house
500 000 and then you sell it four or
five years later and let's say you
the market went way up and you sold your
500 000 house for 800 000
now you made a 300 000 profit if
you now downgrade your life and you go
find an apartment
uh now you're like you have that money
but if you're going to move
to an equivalent house you're not making
any profit because you got to put all
the money in the house
so the only time property to me actually
makes sense is when it's a second
property
so like if i already had a house and
then i bought a house for 500 000 and
then i sold it three years later
oh now i made a profit because it's a
second piece of property
but your home that you live in trying to
make a profit off that
i don't think that that works it don't
seem like sound financial um
sense to me because you're going to talk
about property tax
so then his deficit devil's advocate to
what i was talking about before
so say like rent like i've seen places
that are six thousand dollars a month
rent and i was like well damn that don't
make any sense
and then you sitting at home be like six
thousand dollars you might as well buy a
house okay
so let's talk about what kind of house
you want to get i want i want to get a
million dollar house
i'm just straight up i don't want to i
want if i'm going to get a house i want
to get a dream house
i want to get an ain't even a dream
house in la a million dollars that's
just regular stuff
depending on the neighborhood that you
live in too i'm just letting you know
right now in l.a
a million dollars ain't a lot so let's
say it's a million dollars you got to
put down 20
okay you put down 20 that's 200 000 but
so now you're taking out a 800 000 loan
loan over what is it like what is the
payment gonna be on a 800 000 loan
what is that mortgage payment gonna be
it's actually
a lot it's pricey as hell okay you know
i don't
if i look up like let me let's just do
it right now you know because i'm on the
fly
i should probably already have this
information ready but you know this is
how i do my podcast
so let's go to uh mortgage calculator
all right so you have a so here you go
mortgage calculator all right so let's
go to the loan so here this is perfect
right on google
yes so let's say loan amount eight
hundred thousand oh
no wait wait wait yeah yeah eight
hundred thousand dollar loan
okay 30-year fixed rate
at uh you know a three percent interest
if you get that
this is your credit so your monthly
payment is gonna be 3 600.
okay so that sounds pretty good you know
for some of you it may or may not be
good i don't know here to tell me
but now you're talking about with that
you have to pay
the interest on that you got to pay the
the
the the tax the property tax
you're paying for your water you're
paying for your trash
you're paying for the electric bill
you're paying all the stuff that's now
house stuff
that takes that 3 600 up to
you're talking about five six thousand
dollars a month
you know you're talking about uh you
know five six thousand dollars a month
so
that's damn
you still so you think about what do you
want to do you have to think about
what's
what you want to do for yourself do you
want to have a home
or do you want to you know
or do you like the idea that you don't
you live in a nice
place condo townhouse apartment type
thing and there's amenities
you could just call down and be like hey
the water heater doesn't work can you
come fix this
you know you don't have to worry about
fixing the roof you don't have to worry
about extra tax you just
you know so what kind of peace of mind
are you looking for
you know that's that's the thing you
weigh out all the costs you know
so i don't know where i'm at yeah i
don't know i know eventually i'm going
to have to buy something because you
know rachel when we want to have kids we
want to like settle down you know so
it's like but and where do you want to
live
so it's like i don't know if we're ready
for that at this moment so i'm just
thinking like all right so maybe for a
couple years we find a nice place
it might be a little pricey uh but you
know we have a peace of mind of like ooh
everything's gonna get taken care of and
we live in a nice you know swanky thing
we have our fun for a couple of years
and then it's like all right boom pop
out some babies and all that kind of
stuff who knows
i said where where where you know where
are you at when you're listening to me
talk about this
you know it's like because like home
home ownership is a lot
it's a there's a lot to it it's not just
okay here's my monthly payment and then
you're also stuck with that too
there's no like in case of like you know
what do you do in the case of
an emergency like like a pandemic like
don't ever say
we're never this everyone living right
now is never going to be like ah
nothing like that's ever going to happen
you'll be fine now we're seeing like oh
stuff can happen like this
anything can happen that'll mess up your
whole
life the source of income and all this
kind of stuff so i don't know
you financial people out there you know
i know you have like everybody has an
opinion about whatever they're saying
it's like i say i never say i'm i don't
i'm not claiming to be an expert on
anything
i'm just telling you what i've been
doing my experience i'm comfortable with
i like having my money on hand it's it's
you know it's in the market it's you
know
in bonds and money markets and all this
kind of stuff so i'm like
i'm cool with that i'm ready to like at
any time here put down money on the
thing that i want
and then let's let's you know let's see
what uh see what it is
you know what i mean so i don't know i
don't know what the best thing is
so you let me know again too it's like
it's like finding you know the problem
in
los angeles is like it's la is all about
location
more so than what the house looks like
and the things that you have in the
house like if you you can live in like a
box
in santa monica some some really
tiny things and it's like a 1.5 million
dollar bungalow
or something but you're paying for well
you're right by the beach
but there's other people that value like
oh i want a front yard
i want a backyard i want this i want
that like where is
that house that you know that house
ain't gonna be
in the west side of los angeles for you
know
and you ain't gonna find something like
that for seven hundred thousand dollars
you know what i mean
like you're gonna have to go way out
living like past burbank uh
way down into one on one way in the
valley you have to go to palmdale you
gotta go to all these different places
to find like
this house you know you go oh i love
this house i love how it looks i love
how pretty it is i love this i love the
neighborhood all this kind of stuff that
ain't around
l.a this is like the the dilemma that
you're in you know
it's like ah man
i don't know what to do guys like or do
i buy some swanky condo
i don't know and then like this and this
you know in this
day and age we don't know where income's
coming from
you know i don't know if you know i may
never act again for all we know it could
just be like the money that i have in
the bank is all the money i'm ever going
to have for the rest of my life or i'll
just be like you know
you'll see me like i'll be a i'll be
working at a realtor's office like you
know
is that montez is selling me a house i
don't know what the future's gonna bring
you guys out there are doing you
struggling too you guys are having your
own problems with uh
you know with money there's people
listening to this right now going like
damn i wish i could talk about a million
dollar house you're just trying to
make ends meet so i totally get it we're
all in different places you know what i
mean
like for me my peer group i see all
these people making all this money
doing their podcasts and they're making
like you know you know they're making so
much money
and i'm just struggling to get by well
my thing so my
my reality is like i'm like damn i'm
trying to get i'm trying to get by but
then there's people listening to be like
man
i wish i was making money playing video
games and all the things that i do
so it's like the grass is always greener
on the other side you know but it's just
it is what it is guys you know so we
just you know we just got to like
do the best we can to try to find our
happiness what makes you happy
you know and i'm trying to find that too
and i just i just never have been
someone that wanted to own a home
i've just never been that guy i feel
like i'm an east coast guy
living in los angeles because there's
people that live in the east coast like
they don't they rent their whole life
you know and they're fine they got
disposable income because of that
they're traveling they're doing all
kinds of stuff because their money isn't
tied up in
you know imagine having to tie up like
two or three hundred thousand dollars of
your money
in a home just it's just there
you know you can't do anything with it
maybe you borrow against it i don't know
it just to me it's like well what do i
do
like i don't how do you how do you how
do you manage this
like like how you justify it to yourself
it's just what you find important
you know some people are the kind of
people that like i need to have a yard
i've always wanted to have a yard and
that's
you know that's your dream you know for
other people that might be like no i'm
cool with living in this
you know you know nice apartment that's
like it's off the beaten path and
you know all my money is in in the
market or whatever your thing is so i
don't know you guys tell me in the
comments like what's your
you know just like i'm trying to weed
through the trolls there's so many
trolls in the comments so i'm just
trying
occasionally i find a good gem of a
comment where they're really
engaging in what i'm saying you know
they give a nice back and forth of like
hey this is how i feel about this i
would love to hear your thoughts about
uh
you know what you think that the best
thing is or even your own personal story
of like well i like living this way or
whatever you know what i mean
so i don't know what's up guys me to
talk to you about lucy and i don't mean
i love lucy
so lucy nicotine is a company founded by
cal tech scientists and former smokers
they were looking for a better and
cleaner naked alternative
finally guys a tobacco alternative that
doesn't suck
because they suck most of the time this
one doesn't it was researched and
developed for
three years to be made for people not
patients
that's an important point because the
people that developed it
they were smokers and they were like hey
let's do something that
they themselves would like and they came
up with this lucy was
has created a nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine that comes in
three flavors winter green
cinnamon and pomegranate lucy is also
it also has a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine and a cherry ice
flavor
each and every flavor actually tastes
great
and it's convenient and discreet which
is important too
you can have it everywhere usually you
know somebody's pulling out a cigarette
and that's just annoying they gotta go
outside no matter what the weather is
they feel uncomfortable because
everyone's looking at them like they're
weird or it's like
or the smokers are looking at the people
that don't smoke it's just an awkward
situation so
with lucy gum you can have it anywhere
flights
work on the go even at the gym i don't
smoke
i don't like smokers i don't like smoke
it's just it makes my throat hurt my
nose hurt
i've been at comedy clubs where the
people were like dragons in the front
row just
just blowing smoke and it's just i'm
sick at the end of the week
i dated when someone was that was a
smoker once and it's just it's terrible
their breath stinks all the time their
clothes stink
it's just it's uncomfortable for
everyone so
i don't know man like if it's just
this is a great way if you're trying to
quit you're trying to cut back
lucy gum is the way to go it's 20 20 get
rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is a real deal a subscription to
lucy comes directly to your door
each month it's so simple you don't have
to leave your house because lucy has
delivery
down riffing with griffin listeners
you guys right now go to lucy.c
o and use promo code griffin to get 20
off all products including gum
or lozenges that's lucy dot c o and use
promo code griffin
and check it out also i have to give
this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical
lucy.co and be sure to use promo code
griffin let's get back to the show
so i've been watching um the
bachelorette
so this is this clear chick you know i
don't you guys
listen first of all i reject the premise
of the bachelorette all right i just
i think it's ridiculous you you're not
gonna find true love like this
yeah i looked it up there's like 10
people of 10 people of
of all the episodes of all the shows
bachelorette
bachelor bachelors in paradise all this
nonsense they've come together 10
couples are still together
that's probably actually more than i
even thought there was going to be you
know but this chick 39 years old
claire who's been on the show many times
she was in a finalist it didn't work out
whatever
so she's sitting here and she's sitting
here talking about you know she wants to
find love
and then one dude steps out to damn limo
and she's like i think i met my husband
at 39 years old you should be making
better choices
that's some 22 year old [__] if a 22
year old
girl is standing on a bachelor and some
dude walks out a limo and she says oh
i'm just
he's the one i think i've met my my
husband
i would be like well she's 22 even if
this even if she gets with this guy and
it doesn't work out after four years
she's still young she can get her she'll
mature she'll learn from this
but at 39 what
39 you think man they so she blows the
show up because
all she's doing is talking about this
one guy right who's way younger than her
who i think was on the show to like get
famous
like i don't really think he was on the
show for love so anyway
they bamboozled him into proposing to
her
and the proposal was like everything
about it was awkward
you i don't believe that this guy feels
the way this woman
wants to feel like i don't even think
she feels the way she thinks she feels
i think that she wants to feel that way
and the dude's handsome and she's on tv
and she's like and now her biological
clock is
ticking so they bring a new girl in they
bring this young black girl in
mixed girl she's mixed and uh she's now
she's the new bachelor and you can tell
it's weird the vibe is weird because
when you go on the bachelorette as one
of the dudes you already know who the
bachelorette's gonna be
so you already have an idea that oh i'm
coming to see this
and if you if you were like these dudes
are like one of them's like 31 they're
all in their like early 30s most of them
all right and so you're like okay i'm 31
i like older women
and i'm coming to go see claire you know
she looks you know
she's she's thick she's thick you know
like if you're a black dude
you like she thinks she got big fat ass
booty you know you know her body is
she curvy you know what i'm saying she
curved thick in a good way
so that's what you had in mind right now
they don't drop another chick on you and
she's
this thin mixed black girl 29
28 29 years old that might not be your
thing
you might be like well i don't know if i
signed up for this you know what i mean
now i gotta wrap my brain around like
do what this is the girl that i want i
don't know it's just it's a weird vibe
to me
and you can tell some of the guys are
still thinking about claire like one of
the guys straight up was like i'm in
love with her and i can't stay here
look i i'm you know i i it's not fair to
you because
he tells this to the new girl he's like
it's not fair to you and i'm i'm getting
out i'm out you know what i mean so he
like takes off
right but the rest of them you just kind
of look at him you go i don't know if
this is the the thing i don't know if
this is going to work out
you know but anyway on this the one of
the last episodes
they now show dale and claire and she's
just doing all the talking like i was
telling love and you know
i hate i hate when it's a couple right
and only one person is doing all the
talking in a situation like that like
all the talking rachel probably would
say that that i do all the talking when
she's like on the podcast so i gotta
remember that
but you know what i mean like when
somebody asks a question and then
not only do they do all the talking but
they answer for the other person
you know well you know dale and i you
know
he wants to he's in love with me too
it's like hey [__]
um let him answer because i don't think
he feels this way
and you can tell by he's like because
she's like we want to have what's next
the guy says what's next for you guys he
got
babies you know and they're like i wish
the camera would have
flipped to dale because he had he was he
knew he knew he on tv
so he he had like it was like you have
to slow it down
gonna go with slo-mo but you see a
little like a little oh [__]
hey hey you know what i mean i'm sure
later he was probably like yeah yo don't
you know what i mean what are you doing
i think i just don't see this working
i don't see it working and then she and
she's put all her
eggs into this basket she just totally
blew up the whole bachelorette process
she didn't even allow herself to really
even like even if you were into this
dude dale
take the 20 weeks of the show and prove
it to yourself with him
make him be the one like make him like
fight through all this stuff make him
earn it make him like you know make make
check for yourself make sure using all
these other guys
as a gauge as a limbness test to be like
you know what
um i don't know if because of how this
guy treats me i really realize dale
isn't one or you go you know because of
how this guy treats me i think dale
needs to do a little bit more
and you can even say to him you know i
wish you were doing a little bit more
because
so-and-so was doing this and see if he
rises to the challenge she didn't even
give herself a chance to do any of that
it's so stupid okay i'm just telling you
right now
it's the dumbest it's so dumb and at 39
years old you shouldn't be that
stupid you know what i mean you
shouldn't be that stupid so
i hope it works out for her i could she
could just
she could be the unicorn in this
situation but i doubt it
you know what i mean a doubts it but uh
you know
good luck to her good luck
i was watching um a football game
and i saw a female ref
and i thought to myself
i was thinking to myself how i actually
wasn't thinking about it anymore
that it was a female ref you know
like i just was looking and i thought oh
that ref messed up
and then i saw the ponytail and stuff
and i thought oh that's a female ref
that's a woman you know and i thought oh
look at me i'm not even like there's
nothing in me to be
i'm i'm not even thinking about like oh
man i wonder how these guys
i think i'm thinking to myself because
of technology because of
education because of just being able to
get information on hand like google and
all the stuff that we know about
physiology and human beings and
culture and science and everything how
can we still be in a state
where we feel the way we feel about race
and gender
i think i think we're i always thought
we were way more sexist than we are
racist
in this country you know especially just
the united states i've lived in the
united states
my whole life i've traveled all over the
world and and
the the world hasn't caught up yet like
you want to talk about sexism there's
some sexism going on in other countries
that you'd be like well damn
right but in the united states i think
we're still sick
more sexist than we are anything else
but but in terms of like
you know but i think and when is it
going to go away like when is it going
to be like well you can't really feel
that way anymore
look physically men and women are not
the same men are
stronger you know faster you know you
know that part of it like we're not
going to be able to do the same thing
that way
maybe not in my lifetime who knows maybe
with evolution women are going to be
strong too
i don't know i don't think it's happened
i don't think it will happen i think
that's the nature of
how we were designed you know so in
terms of certain physical things
it's not going to be the same you know
it's like when you watch like the nba in
the wnba all right
i like it i mean basketball is a sort of
sport that
the the fastest most athletic highest
jumping
strongest it makes this the sport itself
look beautiful you know when you watch
it when you were watching michael jordan
play
he was a physical specimen and he was
it was displayed on this court and at
the height of athleticism
like when you look at lebron james he is
six nine with four percent body fat and
he's
the fastest guy on the court and he's
huge and he's
like i like that i want to see that i
want to see
fast paced i want to see high jumping so
that's the kind of basketball i like
when i look at the wnba i don't
see that so i don't like it not because
they're women
i don't like the product okay i've
talked about this before
so in terms of those type of things
we're not gonna be equal
but everything else we need to stop
tripping
okay like like can there be a female
president
of course why not of course there can
if you think about that we've had women
on the supreme court
to me a far more long-lasting
important job than the president you
know
you know what i mean like when what's
happening like the president has current
effects on what's happening in the world
right but like
the supreme court they make decisions
and choices they're they're seeing
people
all the time that that are setting
precedence
that will last generations and we have
women
there making these choices women have
done
so many like outstanding things in our
culture and society and we have
evidence of it to be someone that thinks
women can't do things in this day and
age
it just doesn't make any sense to me you
you're proven
wrong every single
day so at what point is
is that just going to be so archaic
thought process where you just go
someone's like well women need to know
their place
people that still think like that what
how dumb are you now
we're still there you know we're still
there it's like in comedy
i'm so tired of this like oh women are
being held back and
you know at what point are we just going
to get past all that
give everybody the same opportunity and
see what happens
i mean in terms of a business like
comedy it's like there are so many
very funny women they're there
i don't know if it's the kind of
profession that a lot of women even want
to go in
because of like the the come up is so
it's such a lonely depressing process
from where my day and age i mean it's
different now because
you could be an instagram success you
know you could be like you know
a more self-contained safe environment
to cultivate your art
is is the best way to put that so
meaning like you could be
a vine like when vine was big you could
be on fine like brittany ferland a
friend of mine she
became huge online but she was a comic
but you
you hear her talk about she's got social
anxiety and she doesn't like being
around
people so i can't see her driving to
montana by herself to go do an hour and
imbue montana in front of strangers as a
as a female in some weird place by
herself
you know what i mean would she want to
do that i mean i i don't know
so like so that's how i came up so to me
that shows why there aren't a lot of
there are there aren't a lot of women
that came up that way
uh you know because even myself and when
i think about it i'd be in some strange
city
and i and if you really sit and think i
look around and i go damn
i'm actually by myself right now if some
[__] went down
who's got my back it's just me like
there's no like this whole bar can like
tear me up
sometimes i'd be in a place where i'd be
like this is some redneck [__] going on
right here and i
and i'm i'm it's just me with my wits
and i'm doing comedy and i'm being
abrasive and i'm doing you know
at any time this could turn let me
imagine imagine being some
you know young woman you're out in some
strange town by yourself so i don't
think it's the same
i i think that that's the reason why you
don't see as many female comics
now but in 10 years
we're gonna have they're going to be
everywhere because now
you could be of you could be on the
internet you know you could do sketches
you could do youtube sketches you could
do
you could do so many different ways to
to to cultivate your art
and then you go out and then you go out
and be a comic you know you know
you can go to open mics in cities like
los angeles and then you can
you can cultivate an audience in a
different way so now it's a safer more
environment and we're gonna i think that
we're gonna see far more
female comics in the future but it's not
just
let's not make it all about the men are
holding you back
i think there's some also some some
environmental reasons there's
uh why we don't see as many female
accounts but anyways
to get back to my point i digress to sit
and think that women aren't funny
at this point you're just being dumb you
know what i mean
you're just being dumb uh you know so
hopefully our sexism will be curbed but
when i really think about like
so i bring this up to talk about like
when i think about racism now
like at this point in in the world how
can you still be
like what is your reasoning what's your
rationale to be racist
if you're a racist listening to this but
you're probably not unless you're
looking in
for research to be like let's see with
these jigaboos or you know i don't know
who
who you are out there that if you like
you know or if you're or if you're some
secret white power person or if you are
if you're one of these people that has
these thoughts that you know
you know white the white man is superior
that's already been proven wrong like
you've already that's already been
debunked
it was debunked in 1930 you know
you know the hitler was talking about
the aryan race
the superior race and then freaking was
it jesse owens or whoever that was
demolished you know what i mean like
like
if you're a white person and that thinks
that white people are superior
in what because it's not athletics
you know what i mean it's it's never
going to be athletics
maybe who knows i don't see that
happening in my lifetime
what i'm saying is we already have
empirical data like we have facts and
data
how can you still feel the way you feel
like if you're somebody that's like you
know you
you i wonder how it must be for people
who are like a generational racist
and you think white people are the best
right and then you turn on the tv
and you know do you you must not watch
the nba you know you must not watch like
even in the nfl
which is still like a good old boy thing
look how many black quarterbacks there
are
five six more years it's gonna be all
black quarterbacks
athletic quarterbacks even though even
if it's like a white
they're going to be they're going to
have to be athletic to play that
position
and now it's like we're going to look
back and remember we're not a
quarterbacks for white
that's how it's going to be you know
it's like the black athlete
has already it's already proven that the
black athlete is superior
so how are you still a hater you know
like
you i'm saying is you can't use that as
your reasoning for hating
hating like so many you look at someone
like lebron james who's this like
superior god-given just
the genetic lottery he won and he's but
he's also brilliant
he's he's he's going to be a billionaire
because of his business event business
ventures and
all that he does off the court you know
it's like
how do you what rationale are you using
to hate black people what what is it
please justify it
and then you want to talk about you know
then there's people that talk about well
look at the crime
you know how many crime-ridden poor
white neighborhoods there are two
then you that has that has nothing to do
with race
it's about economics it's about
what what's going on in those
neighborhoods what's going on in those
school systems what resources are we
putting
you can trace it back we have data now
we have 30 40 years of information to
look and say
you know why this neighborhood's bad and
it has a lot of crime well there's
liquor stores on the corners there's gun
shops there's
the educational system is broken down
there's you we now can look at it and
see
all the reasons why these things happen
they have nothing to do with race so
how are you still racist i'm asking you
really if you're at home watching by
yourself tell tell your
ask yourself huh i wonder why do i hate
other races
why i mean i think if you really look
boiled down to it you might find that
there are other
reasons maybe you have some some real
rational reasons for thinking the way
you think
but it's still dumb it's still
ridiculous but
it can't be because of the color of
someone's skin that makes no sense
anymore
how can you make sense like you could
just google like
are white people and black people
genetically
different or whatever kind of things you
can google about race
google's gonna put you in your place oh
i just made a rhyme
look at that um anyways i don't know
guys
i just i i'm sitting here i just was
thinking about it like
why is there still racism when we have
so much information
to prove ourselves to be stupid for
thinking that way
at what point is it just gonna be like
you know somebody said something racist
that we could just be like really
really is that is that where you're
going with it because it's not gonna
bother us anymore
it's just gonna be because it really
boils down to rich and poor that's what
that's
it's class warfare right now it's class
warfare
all right and we you really have to
start seeing that
it's about the haves and the have-nots
and those people are all different
shapes and colors and sizes and genders
man
look at it all right that's i don't know
why i went on that rant
but i did it is what it is
funny story i wanted to go over some
funny stories that i saw on the news try
to keep it light
um this this this um what do you call it
this episode
like where what did i see i saw
some funny um weird stories
like this one guy he won the lottery
and he'd been playing the same lottery
numbers for 35
years and i was like
damn he finally did it but it made me
think of a story from my
my own life so i had a buddy of mine and
he
so his his mom was previously divorced
so she was dating this guy
i'll never forget it too so like she
they played the lottery all the time and
they had their numbers and she
told he told that the boyfriend told his
mom
to buy the lottery ticket and
gave her these numbers go buy these to
make sure you make sure you buy my
lottery ticket and she didn't
buy the tickets and those numbers
hit they would have won six million
dollars
let me tell you something that [__]
would be dead
do you hear what i'm saying like i don't
like can you imagine you tell
your significant other buy these numbers
today
okay make sure you buy and they don't
buy it and that number hits
you got to break up i can't be with you
ever i can't be around you because for
the rest of my life
no matter what happens i'm bringing that
[__] up
you know no matter what you do i'ma be
like remember when you didn't
buy them tickets and we could have had
six million dollars yeah so you need to
go
vacuum the living room like you you have
no
leg i would never get over it
like never would you get over it i would
never get over it
like for the rest of my life i would
look at this you would i couldn't stay
with you because i would look at you and
be like
you cost me six million dollars
like [__] get out of my face
like go i you need to leave the country
i need to be far away from you because
you cost me six million dollars it's
just weird but i don't know
you imagine this guy
after 35 years you finally win but it's
still luck i mean it's
it's all luck i mean god how many times
have you ever thought god if i won the
lottery what would you do
what would you do if you guys won the
lottery you know i always say if i won
the lottery i would collect call
all my friends
yeah you ain't ever gonna see me again
it's click off from eric
you know from the caribbean
i'll be on the island someplace
what would you do you win the lottery
like
i don't know what's the first thing you
would do
like you see the number you're at home
like play it out in your head like if i
was at home
and i'm looking at it because i remember
one time i was in vegas and i won
keno you know keno's like a little basic
lottery i was i remember i was in this
restaurant
and i went two friends and so i had like
a six pick you know
six pick and i always used to pick the
same numbers 3 12 72
uh 27 i had these like numbers that i'll
always pick
you know because i love playing keno
because you could sit in a restaurant
you can gamble while you're eating and
it's exciting i love that the feeling
you know
so we're talking then i see the thing
so so like i got the thing in my hand
and i'm engaged in the conversation i'm
like yeah yeah i know ah what's up i
know right
then damn we should have hit that 12.
boom boom boom three
yeah you know bob you know i know i know
we should bet on the game
12. oh yeah um
yeah we should have put 100 on that 72
and i was like oh and then it's just
like
the whole room went dark you know what i
mean and it was just me and the kino
board
you know what i mean and
then it was like like i remember the
last number was three so
i got all five numbers and then they're
starting to talk to me they're like yo
hey dude what's up with you and then i
start going like this three
three three you know and it's like
i got that thing in my hand and then of
course you're in vegas so everybody
already knows
the whole restaurant now gets it oh man
this guy's about to win keno
so everybody's like three the whole
place was like
three three the whole restaurant was
cheering for me and then the three came
up and i was like
you know the whole place was like you
know and then it just died off and that
was it
so i remember that feeling it's like so
imagine
what you would feel like if like you're
at your house
you're at your place and you're looking
at the lottery like
you know i don't know you you might not
have been looking at it live because i
don't i don't even know if they do it
live anymore
i don't even know if they do it live but
imagine you're like sitting there
and you're like looking in the paper or
you went online like this week's lottery
numbers
and you saw the numbers and you you go
oh wait a minute that looks
where's my ticket did you get your
ticket and you match it and that moment
you're like
oh my god like what would you do
what would you do in that moment
i don't know i'm trying to think like
you know what i would do is i wouldn't
tell anyone right away i wouldn't even
tell rachel i would try to contain my
excitement
it would be so hard like if she was home
i would i would be like
right now look at that you know what i
mean we break it up
no i'm kidding no but i'd probably be
like if i could
i would hold it in and not tell her
anything right
get my lottery get the money it's all in
the bank you know what i mean get it all
set up
and then like you know get a private jet
to like france or something oh damn in a
pandemic or go someplace you can go
independent like bora bora is open
you know what i mean i would tell her
back just baby pack an overnight bag
cause we're gonna go do a little thing
you know what i mean and then a limo
picks us up
you know what i'm saying we would go to
like the the private jet
and i'm talking about the good private
jet you know what i mean like the dope
one because you let's say you want like
50 million dollars
you're getting like that private jet
service where it's like the red carpet
is out there
and she's like what's going on you'd be
like i don't know i don't
know i don't know what happened i don't
know why this is this is strange i think
this is like something weird you know
you fly there then you like lavish your
you know your loved one and you know i
would just lavish her and stuff and then
just
guess what we don't ever have to go back
if we don't want to because i won the
lottery
that'd be great i'd put i'd put my mom
someplace like super fancy
dementia care type thing make sure my
stepdad is taken care of
then after that i just have a few
friends that i would like i would look
after you know what i mean i
i got a few friends i would be like hey
man i'm gonna put this
just some money for you or something you
know i don't know
those are the people i would you know
this people take care of i think if i
won the lottery
this week i would this is how i would
propose to rachel like to get her a ring
even though we're
we're like engaged but it's not official
until i buy our ring you know
and she keeps telling me like just wait
get the right ring you know
i'm i'm not i'm being patient i think i
would want to do is like would take her
to like tiffany's or something
and then get down on one knee and go
whatever you want
[Laughter]
would that be a good proposal i haven't
got
i got some good proposals actually by
the way i've gotten some good ones
like even her mom sent me one that was
like a horseback riding
one no a horse and carriage take on a
horse and carriage ride
her brother told me one about something
about the beach i gotta look and see
but he doesn't know her that well
because he was like you should surprise
her this way
and he just doesn't notice she don't
like surprises so i don't know if that's
a good one but
i'm trying to come up with some ones
because she already told me i don't want
it to be in front of people
i don't want food involved you know what
i mean she don't want to have to dig
through some soup to find a ring you
know what i mean
so uh i don't know so i'm still looking
for that guys if you got some proposal
ideas make sure you like hit me up with
those
but uh i can only dream of winning a
lottery
right don't waste your money though but
occasionally look if it's like
500 million spend a dollar you never
know
you know you help that money's helping
schools you're doing your part
so i can help schools and also win 500
million dollars that that's a win-win
for
the school got you a pencil and i got
you know
the life of my dreams so i don't know
anyways well i think that's it guys i
think that's it for this week a little
solo riffing with griffin rachel
rachel was busy all week so i couldn't
really lock her down to do another
episode but probably next week rachel be
back on
uh you know i did my real world advice
from a grown-ass man separately but
nobody watched it
you know what i mean like nobody it's
like it's got such little views and
listens that i was like maybe you really
don't like this i don't know or maybe
you only like it when it's with an
episode
you guys gonna let me know in the
comments i don't know if people liked it
or not but it is what it is i'm trying
to do different things but you know i
don't even know if you guys even like my
real world advice from a grown smash
segment but make sure you uh follow me
on twitch
if you want to watch me game i game
every single day
eric griffin gaming on twitch i put
those videos up on youtube
i've been doing this thing where they
have like private war zone matches so
i'm doing that with the fans on
saturdays so saturday morning 11 a.m
pacific time
uh i'm doing private war zone matches
and it was so fun last week you could
look at my instagram and see some of the
things that we did
just to have like 60 70 people like you
know that you sort of know
you know that we interact with all the
time or you know you can have you know
you can you could bring your friends too
if you want to come
if you have like five friends you know
that play warzone you guys want to play
like
with each other because it wouldn't be
great if you to be in a solo match
and you know your friends there you're
all trying to kill each other i mean i
think that that's like a fun thing about
the private war zone matches so
let me know if you guys you know just
come you know saturday morning 11 a.m
come i'll be on twitch eric griffin
gaming and then i just you know i make
it open i open my thing up and people
just join and then we just go have fun
so uh look out for that and as always
thank you for listening subscribing
please share please give me your
feedback and your comments try to be
respectful as you can please i can't
stand some of you troll
[__] but most of you are really
respectful so keep those messages coming
and we'll see what we do
see how it goes and we'll continue to
you know grow and make the show better
and
you know blah blah blah like i always
say every week but i appreciate you
listening and i'll see you next week